where can i find the jedi
take the foundling to the city of
caledon on the forest planet of corvus
there you'll find ahsoka tano tell her
you were sent by bogotan
before we get to the breakdown and
discussion of ahsokitano
i want to say how damn good this episode
was
i've already seen it twice and i want to
watch it again bo katan
translate so well over to live action i
couldn't be happier
and this episode was just a blast to
watch from the action to the story to
the pacing to the visuals it all just
worked for me
let's give bryce howard a star wars film
anyway over to ahsoka tano
will we see her in the next episode
unfortunately i don't think we'll see
her in the next episode
because the next episode is directed by
karl weathers
and apparently the episode is called the
siege
where the mandalorian rejoins old allies
for a new mission
and judging by the footage from the
trailers it looks like
um we'll see a battle sequence on
navarro with the old crew
um cara dune grief cargo and the mando
back together but i reckon would
definitely see ahsoka in episode 5
because that episode is actually
directed by dave felony
and that's one of the main reasons why i
don't think we'll see her next episode
because i don't think he would want
um you know another director like carl
weathers to um
direct ahsoka i think he would want the
pleasure to um
address the episode himself which um
episode 5 is also written by dave filoni
so it looks like we have to wait another
week
to see ahsoka tano which is okay guys i
think the weight will definitely be
worth it because you know just look at
bo katan from this episode she
translated so well
to live action and i couldn't be happier
so yeah tell me guys in the comment
section
below what you thought of this episode
and are you guys excited to see us okay
though with that out of the way please
like and subscribe and i'll catch you
guys in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
you